why is this baby naked in the woods at
night we found a baby in Northern
Thailand moping around we saw a baby on
a road yeah what the [__] there was a
house like 200 yards up like is this
your baby and she like oh my God thank
you so much do you guys have cigarettes
uh a [__] bait baby oh d a bait be a
bait baby so they put the baby out so
people save the baby get some cigarettes
oh my God couple lucies they used to do
a thing where they throw a baby and you
instinctually catch it and then they
pickpocket you oh my god did you have to
catch
it yes how Wild this part of the world I
was in thaan I was watching this whole
family on a moped there was a baby it's
like a starfish baby the guy was riding
the baby was sitting here the wife was
behind him pull it up I like this is
insane you have a baby hang on both
sides